how go one breath I don't know what this
is but welcome back to Jenna Brasil a
this is a leg
I guess his name is sander with this
jump I don't even know where to begin
jump but let's go
oh I made a fresh line too much pull the
lever jump it I can do it I can do it I
just [ __ ] did it
no leave without me all right easier
than yesterday but yesterday I was kind
of pissed off but that's okay we're not
fit back anymore
don't read notes shall we I get it
ah why did I tell ya logging operations
mining operations have been moving along
say that violently cleared the member
and have finished setting up the lift
system for moving worker now you clearly
didn't [ __ ] good job at all of all
miners in the state-of-the-art gas masks
and this seems to have ah okay that
happens get despite the hazardous nature
of our operation here we managed this
tremendous feeding an extremely showed
him out of time all right we suffering
one casualty
that's gadna vast improvement from our
previous effort I'm very note I have
Sitapur small rights at the bottom of
the central in Sencha I guess that's
where we're going I mean I could only
assume I'm gonna pick up tuna - this is
the water fun we are going to urinate
and we're done right Scout that crowbar
huh hey cheesy over that [ __ ] all right
cut it's like
sounds like you're popping us by a paint
I don't even know what it's alright
thanks is kind of creepy more of a Janos
I don't know what I think about that Wow
Wow
again which way do I go what care okay
that was a waste of time
hi Jennifer I know you love me I know
you care that is what are you dead you
dead or what strong with your eyes
brother I don't know if he's dead or not
let's confirm if he's dead
do you like this [ __ ] is that he is
better than the dead dude you know dude
ah [ __ ] we gotta go down here no way I
would not go down here just sayin
all right all right how mama mama pewds
you're here thank you here sign them up
barrel all right what do we got
sure but I know you're working with the
battles ah all right you got a drill
yeah what what what why are we going oh
no that's gonna be a bit odd uh what am
I going oh
dun da I'm an idiot all right over here
okay da my breasts I got this under 100%
control nothing bad can happen if I'm
here don't worry you're scared I'll get
a kitten or something I don't know all
right there we go
wait a second
wasn't me here I swear I was there or
maybe it's just a menstruation paddle I
always get those mixed up you never know
these days with menstruation it could
happen
Wow
Wow I swear to God I heard someone
breathing oh that is creepy
okay this is done
as soon and so lament Dona I don't know
oh we made it out of life cool so now
we're gonna go back to if I can remember
ah we gotta jump there ah I heard it if
I remember correctly there will be sure
alright to Narnia and you're back aren't
you glad to go to Narnia son of a [ __ ]
what if I stop moving it oh there you
are thank you that's right yet left
behind me
alright to adventure and beyond come on
man God holy [ __ ] that is everything
here I wonder where that miner went
probably somewhere now all right here he
comes folks Billy
all right Oh son of a [ __ ] I did it
alright alright alright let's not oh all
right
got it got it yeah
ah save that [ __ ] like a [ __ ] Wow I
don't even care you see that [ __ ] badass
Oh elite pro son of a I got two more all
right which way which way which way
which way this is the wrong way I don't
even [ __ ] care because all right now
we go down to the dress drill the hole
and everything would be splendid Nupur
Isaac that's a new word I invited Ben
today whatever no matter how dark the
moment love and hope is always possible
it's not true I mean if you are able to
take a really bad [ __ ] love and hope is
not gonna help you
does sayin sorry
probably maybe hello I got the feeling
I'm watched in this cousin sorry I don't
like it so [ __ ] dark shell ball
camera 1 so there was someone up there
he's faster this scaping then this is a
[ __ ] stone floor you can't cry ouch
I don't remember that was open or not
alright good for you you walk in that
stop okay there's nothing in that room
anyway [ __ ] pointless room this is
the fapping spider room it is isn't it
oh it started it about out like [ __ ]
yeah um
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I hate him I hate him
a lot
I'm not gonna lie I don't know why I
would lie about that
we need it don't we I can't pick it up
baka
bah all right well I don't know let's
find the way down to the dress thing or
whatever it was I think it's here yeah
there and then you go right yeah yeah
that's how I roll that's how I get all
the ladies I want their time that's it
that's how I want that time all right
which one is it probably this one oh I'm
a genius I drew what do I do now
oh I don't even [ __ ] remember picking
that up but okay whatever I'm supposed
to do with this I have no [ __ ] clue
my let's go what is going on what is
going on what is going on what is going
on what is going on why do you go now
what is going on what is that need what
is that mean
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm running I'm running I'm running I'm
at a sexy and he knows it
I don't know the [ __ ] spider don't
you die holy [ __ ]
I shut up music try to tease me and [ __ ]
shut up no no one likes you music oh you
got his helmet back who put your helmet
back on son
I sure tell didn't do it oh you piece of
paper what am I supposed to do with this
oh yeah mining operations acid
experiments I finished my expend now I
can easily gain liquid acid just by
mixing water told me for a new way of
torturing people okay fan-fucking-tastic
what am I supposed to do with it what
are you doing here you and I inherit a
shop you don't know who you're talking
to son
whatever
all I got is better than fapping spiders
ah why do you do that I hate you son of
a spider why is it done
[Applause]
he's fast no no no okay holy [ __ ] no I
don't even know where to go I was a
girly scream I ever had in a long
[ __ ] time I got a lie
all right maybe were done yet I don't
know let's just try to go back they
don't give you [ __ ] come on
no notes I have this note of their
mining operations drilling yeah that's
how I got them drill [ __ ] defuses
hell man what a year died down right
away when I'm talking to ya ah are you
running away when I'm talking to you
what is your problem huh what is what is
your deal what your name is Lisa well
holy [ __ ] least I wouldn't you tell me
what are we doing in here what you don't
know ah [ __ ] me Lisa well don't do it
technically Lisa
happy birthday happy you see that [ __ ]
is this here we go here Prison West Wing
I don't remember going there maybe we
had something there whoa progress
alright so please alright not wasting
[ __ ] let's go up here
this is where we keep all the fruits
okay careful not to go near the prison
door because the El Arabia is there no
way the doors are open they are the
servants will take care o their servant
why of cars well it's been a big fan of
serving my calls bucks baited around
servants alright she's kind of more
interesting me later just finding it out
there alright put you there I'm glad I
went to this dead-end
I feel so free love with joy I love dead
ends
it's so pointless and it makes you
wonder why the [ __ ] you went there
let's go wait I came from there or did I
yep came from there let's keep walking
up stop what okay I'm sorry
sorry I'm didn't waste a Man Thing only
you're I did this guy should kind of
cool the map design
I like it it's unique and creepy at the
same time it's cool I like it
do I have to say it again torture room
huh that's not sound like a good room to
me unless okay
well this is where Lisa told me to go so
it's gotta be it I'm just sayin [ __ ] I'm
glad you're with me lion how are their
sawing and stuff going on it
Lisa Lisa I'm so glad you're here yes I
don't know how okay you can keep all
right Lisa this thing but like videos
enjoyed subscribe to come up I thought I
saw someone it's creepy scheduled this
day no see you never ironic
funny if only you saw what i can see you
would understand I want you sure -
friendly right now